[Music]
when I was looking up Center for
artificial intelligence in society one
of the first thing that struck me is
that it's a group of department of
computer science working with the
Department of Social Work in my
knowledge you can't get computer science
to work with computer engineering and so
this is really interesting that there is
an interdisciplinary effort in in in
University of Southern California that
there's a vision to understand that this
kind of work happens when we work
together we have today three folks who
will be presenting milind Eric rice and
mr. Adil Khanna but we also have Jordan
Davis and Phoebe bionis who were also
faculty at you using c-span and Brian as
well I'm sorry well thank you
this is so exciting we've been working
on trying to put this together in
collaboration with Microsoft Research
and it's absolutely fantastic that this
has come together and we are very
excited my name is Melinda may and along
with me here as we just mentioned we
have very Christ and this Adam kena who
will jointly give this presentation and
I should start my clock because I want
to be done in ten minutes
and then Eric and bistra will take over
and they'll speak for ten minutes each
Phoebe via nosey and Jordan and so and
Brian Wilder is our student so together
this represents bulk of the center's
faculty so just to very quickly tell you
about our Center we are this USC Center
for AI in society a case it's an
interdisciplinary center the six key
faculty are all present here today
there's 24 PhD students we only got one
here but the remaining ones are back
there and we'll talk to them later a
focus is AI for societal problems and we
are very keen on starting projects in
India and to show our keenness I wanted
to show two slides no politics so we
were very thrilled to be in the audience
when
Prime Minister talked about AI for
societal benefits in Mumbai and so very
inspiring and then this was in February
and then then in June Honorable External
Affairs Minister held a roundtable
meeting on artificial intelligence and
there too we were honored to be invited
and that's me you can see hiding behind
in the back but this is again we talked
about how AI could be used for societal
benefits so we are very keen on starting
projects here and just to give you a
flavor for the kinds of projects that we
have done at USC our focus has been on
three areas public safety and security
public health and conservation and I'll
give a general overview and then Eric
will talk in depth about public health
and Beast Robert conservation so the
basic problem is focused on is how to
optimize our limited intervention
resources using AI in order to solve
societal problems so let's take public
health Eric will discuss this in more
depth but give you a concrete example
hiv/aids is a big problem with the
homeless population in Los Angeles how
to spread information about HIV amongst
the homeless youth we can't talk to
everybody there 6,000 homeless youth and
so we have to identify key peer leaders
will spread information we show that AI
techniques are far more effective in
finding these peer leaders to spread
information compared to traditional
methods and this we have done with pilot
tests on the ground so these are always
things that we test out but can we try
this out for TB prevention and for other
kinds of health challenges for
conservation we've been working a lot in
Uganda for the past several years so the
Uganda wildlife authority to protect
endangered wildlife here with machine
learning we predict where poachers will
attack with traps or snares and remove
them before they kill animals you've
done this for past several years a lot
of snares have been removed animals
hopefully have been saved and with
drones getting infrared video detecting
Porter's and our animals on the fly from
these infrared videos so that they can
be stopped bistra we'll discuss this in
much more depth we have also a lot of
interesting public safety and security
counterterrorism we've worked a lot with
government agencies coast guard the
Transportation Security Administration
large number of targets to protect where
and when to Patrol
where and when to put security
checkpoints and so forth this is not the
focus of this workshop not going to talk
about it but these the software that's
actually in use for you know over a
decade by these agencies just to tell
you that we are very interested in
getting this software deployed and in
use this is now spreading to other
countries like Israel and Argentina and
so forth so I wanted to talk a little
bit about the fact when we solve
problems we have firmly believe in
interdisciplinary partnerships so to
that end we've really worked with the
coast guard patrolling with them on
their Coast Guard ports in New York or
patrolled in the forests of Malaysia
with the violet conservation agencies
eric has spent 15 years working with
homeless populations in Los Angeles and
so on so when we start solving problems
we always started emerging ourselves in
the domain and trying to get data this
is not a situation where data is ready
made available we are very interested in
trying to identify get the right kind of
data following that of course the next
step is predictive analytics that is
given the data can we predict which
cases may be high risk which may be low
risk many AI systems stop there just
predicting high and low risk cases but
we at our Center is interested are
interested in doing more we have limited
intervention resources can we go beyond
and do prescriptive analytics that is
where to take our limited resources and
place them so that we get the highest
benefit not just identify high and low
risk but which cases should we take on
given our limited resources
now many AI systems will stop there but
our Center we really are very interested
in going once there beyond and testing
this prescription in the field and
understanding where we have gone right
and wrong so that this can then inform
our data collection very quickly just as
an example in the wildlife conservation
domain data collection would be where
are the snares place based on that
predictive analytics would say where are
the high-risk areas in the park where
are the low-risk areas in the park
prescriptive analytics would say where
should you Patrol given that you know
high and low risk areas and finally
testing in the field would say send out
the patrollers get them to Patrol do we
get the results that we want or not and
if we don't then change our
so as I said all of the cases that I
talked about a deployed test that we are
very interested in actually testing
things in the field and not just writing
papers and so this is very very
important to our Center I just wanted to
talk about a few projects that we have
in my last four minutes or so that may
inform you about some of the ongoing
efforts at our Center Eric and Vista
will talk more of course
so for example AI can help in obesity
prevention efforts this is an idea of
how could we optimize public outreach
efforts within limited budgets can we
help improve TB treatment by predicting
defaulters and I understand um it may
discuss some of the work that that's
going on in this context but let me take
on this childhood obesity prevention so
this is in the United States a very
large problem childhood obesity and so
in the Antelope Valley which is north of
Los Angeles where our university is
located there's a low resource community
where only 10% the kids are perceived by
their parents to be healthy and so we
are working with our School of Medicine
to try to see if we can prevent
childhood obesity so this is done
because the basic idea is trying to get
peers to influence parents to get
children to eat healthy in other words
get mothers to cook together healthy
food but which mothers should cook
together because that's the way we will
determine health outcomes and so
essentially if you look at it from a
graph each of these nodes you could
imagine is a mother the red node is the
mother whose children are unhealthy so
who do we pair this mother with in order
to get the kinds of health outcomes we
want so should we get this one to
connect with this one and then maybe
drop a connection to this other one
because that's not an unhealthy
relationship or from this kind of a
group and so forth so those are the
kinds of questions we can solve this is
work that's going on in Antelope Valley
this is something that we are very
interested in deploying another project
that's also ongoing is work in urban
peak this is in Denver a homeless
shelter here we have a social network of
youth
were addicted who abuse substances these
are shown by the red nodes the black
nodes are ones who are healthy and the
question then becomes can we create
groups so that we reduce substance abuse
and so can we partition the graph
creating groups where healthy outcome
prevails because the peers can influence
this red node because they have been cut
off from this other red node in order to
change their behavior so these kinds of
things trying to figure out which kinds
of partitions can perform better so that
we avoid deviancy training because if
you incorrectly create partitions then
actually addiction increases so we want
to reduce the addiction by creating the
right kinds of partitions a third
challenge that we've recently taken on
is trying to look at infectious diseases
in India we know there's half a million
deaths due to TB how to get more
patients into treatment so there's
outreach effort and some of you may know
a whole lot more about this but this is
what we understand that there are
different outreach effort the question
is you know this different outreach
efforts may reach different segments of
the population different geographical
areas who to target how to spread our
limited budget and so we've constructed
a multi agent model for disease spread
and in AI algorithm that based on
realistic data can do expand
experimental evaluation based on this we
show that our models can do better than
what has been done a status code now
clearly this is done as a simulation
exercise based on realistic data that we
can get a hold off but the basic point
is if you have limited resources how to
invest them in order to kind kind of get
the right kinds of outcomes based on
whatever data we have so that's the type
of work that we can do so I'll end here
by saying there is a tremendous
potential for use of AI for social idle
benefits we are very interested in
applications here we worked in Africa in
South America and we are really keen on
pushing this forward so it's 10 minutes
and I'm going to hand this over to Eric
to start his 10 minutes I'm really
excited to be here as well
this is my opportunity to talk about two
projects that are really near and dear
to my heart which are working with
homeless teenagers so I've been working
with homeless teenagers and young adults
for the last 15 years in Los Angeles and
I'm gonna talk about one project that's
on home that's on HIV prevention and
another project that's on housing and
the point of this is really to give the
especially the folks who are in the NGO
space in this room a sense of how we
approach our work and also some of the
kinds of problems that we can tackle
with technologies that maybe are things
that you haven't thought about before so
the first thing that I want to mention
and in Jordan Davis here is with me as
well from the social at school social
work is that social work researchers
we're very invested in very intimate
partnerships with non-government
organizations and government
organizations so Jordan and I have
actually both done intervention work you
know small group work with in his case
youth who've been in substance abuse
treatment programs in my case with
homeless with homeless teenagers and so
we don't just do research work but we
actually do work out in the world that
social service providers do we do it
hand in hand with them so this is
actually a picture of me actually
interacting with a young person out in
the field this is something that happens
on a regular basis the issue is that
there are 4.2 million homeless youth in
the United States each year there's
three million are three hundred million
citizens of the United States we were
not nearly as large as you all are but
homelessness is a big problem what this
is suggested recently is that almost 1
in 10 teenagers between the ages of 13
and 24 will experience homelessness
every year so this is becoming an
increasingly large problem as the class
divide becomes larger in the United
States HIV prevalence is nearly 10%
amongst this group of people so we
really need to think about how can we
target this very large group of people
who need HIV prevention work so our
community partners in this context are
three different drop-in centers where
homeless youth can go in access services
one is a safe place for youth and other
is my friend's place another is the Los
Angeles LGBT Center
where we've done this work these are
partner organizations that I've been
working with for about 15 years and what
we're trying to do in this context is a
peer led intervention so the idea is we
don't have enough resources to do HIV
prevention work with every single
homeless youth in the city but we can
find strategic folks who are the right
people who can be our advocates who we
can train to go and do health outreach
work in their community the complexity
of this however is that the social
networks of these homeless youth even
within one of these centers are these
dizzying arrays so what we're stuck with
is a problem that I like to think of as
be very akin to the problem that Google
Maps solves so we're trying to do
optimal planning and what we have is a
network where there's a lot of noise
there's a lot of uncertainty we might
not know exactly who's connected to whom
people might get into fights with one
another and stop being friends with one
another so this is a moving target much
like traffic in a city as a moving
target but like with Google Maps where
you want a specific solution we want a
specific solution to who should we pick
is this small group of young people that
we can train to do this activity so we
developed algorithms that parse the
community into smaller sections find
specific key leaders I'm gonna spare you
all of the math just show you pictures
today and what's exciting about this is
that when we compare this these systems
to the standard ways in which Public
Health and Social Work have done this in
the past what we see here is that the AI
driven solutions far outperform the the
usual status quo public health solutions
we're looking at you know in these
networks we were seeing about 70% of the
target youth we're getting messages
about HIV prevention versus only about
27% in the standard group and then when
we are thinking about people going out
and getting HIV testing which is one of
the important things you need to do if
you're going to link people into
antiretroviral drugs is that we see
again a big difference here in terms of
those who were reached by our messaging
we had about almost 30 to 40% of those
young people went and got an HIV test
and so therefore it could start to get
engaged in treatment if they needed it
for
is the standard public health arm of
this field deployment where we actually
had no new testers in that space so we
see this not as a perfect solution but
when millon was putting out this this
pathway of going from collecting data
community part with community partners
than doing predictive analytics and then
doing prescriptive analytics and then
doing field tests this is one example of
a project that we've been invested in
for several years and we're actually
currently right now just about to finish
out a trial where we've enrolled nearly
a thousand homeless young people over
the last year and a half into this
program and what's Wonder one last thing
that I'll mention is that what seems to
be of great benefit of some of these AI
programs is that in an age in which
especially young people are very excited
about technology these are two young men
who were picked by our algorithms to be
become peer leaders and they felt very
empowered by this entire experience and
they actually started to do much better
and actually both of these young men
ended up getting jobs in an in housing
within about two years after within the
two years after this initial program
went forward so the other program that I
want to talk about is a little bit
earlier in its development this is
something that I've been working very
closely with Phoebe vaya knows who's not
gonna get a chance to stand up and speak
but I'm going to get to actually speak
for her which is not entirely fair but
here we are working on housing so I've
been working with organizations
governmental organizations and
non-governmental organizations in the
United States around housing issues for
the last five or six years this has been
something as a relatively more recent
body of my work but again the issue is
one of scarcity so we have this huge
number of young people who are on the
streets and we don't have nearly enough
resources to give them the United States
is this very wealthy country with a very
broken social welfare system so we are
working with the Los Angeles housing
service authority this is the group a
governmental organization in Los Angeles
that is a bit too is that both the city
and the county in which we're located
and they provide most of the housing
resources for homeless youth and so
they're our partner in this particular
effort
and what we're trying to do here is
something that is very much like uber so
what the idea is is that we have a small
number of houses that are available at
any one time we've got a large number of
people that are waiting for housing so
how do we match just like uber would
match drivers to riders through this
traffic how do we match the right people
to the right housing resources so that
we can do two things we can optimize the
success of those housing resources
because since they're so few we don't
want to waste any precious resource but
the other idea is that we want to make
sure that people are treated fairly so
there's a lot of discussion right now in
the ethical area of AI around bias and
algorithms and that if you just train
systems that are built on former
datasets that may have a lot of implicit
bias in them you will just reproduce
these biases so what we really want to
do in this is we want to improve on two
things fairness as well as the actual
efficiency so the current system for
housing allocation is very simplistic
what you get is young people are asked
about 50 questions and from these 50
questions they are assigned a score that
ranges from 1 to 17 and depending on
whether they score 8 or higher they get
really good services if they score 4 to
7 they get rental subsidies and if they
score less than 4 they get nothing we've
approached this in the way that milind
described and I guess this is not
showing up so well so this says machine
learning about prediction and then this
is going to be policies that are that
are prescriptive well but what we really
want to do with these policies is we
want to make sure that they're
interpretable right this simplistic
scoring mechanism although it's maybe
not the most effective thing in the
world which I'll show you in a minute it
least is something that people can
understand so we want to make sure that
the AI that we build in these in these
social service contexts is one that
wherein people can explain to their
clients that they're working with why
they are or are not eligible for
services we can't just deny people
housing and say well the computer says
you don't get housing so what we're
interested in is optimized
our success like uber but we also want
to make sure that we avoid
discrimination one of the big issues in
the United States is racial
discrimination so these are Hispanic and
black youth these are traditionally
populations that have suffered a lot of
discrimination and marginalization in
the United States this I want you to
just only focus it on the top and the
bottom here that I don't have enough
time to explain everything in between
but the top is the current system as it
exists and what you see here is the
white youth that are purple they're
benefiting at much higher rates than the
Hispanic and the black youth Phoebe's
algorithm is able to change this so this
is a computational experiment where
we're doing some prescriptive analytics
and we're saying if we changed who we
gave the housing interventions to so we
didn't just do this simplistic system
that is currently in place we could
greatly reduce by looking at the
individual characteristics of these
young people we could greatly reduce the
inequalities here and what's even more
exciting again focus on the top and the
bottom is that you can see this is the
overall successful number of outcomes in
the system as a whole and what we're
able to do is we're able to create a
bump of about 10% in this system which
is actually a really big deal this ends
up being thousands of people when you're
talking about the scale of homelessness
that you have in Los Angeles where we've
got 50,000 people on the streets on any
given night so with that I will turn
things over to bestir who is also going
to talk to you about some of the
implications that we've had recently
case also has a lot of projects that
involve using AI for wildlife
conservation as you all know there's
been a dramatic decline in the
populations of many species many of them
in dangers like tigers and elephants as
well as rhinos and and giraffes
unfortunately a lot of this decline is
also due to poaching for illegal
wildlife trade so case over the last
four to five years has actually
partnered with several NGOs such as WCS
WWF and Pantera to try to help them to
develop AI based tools to make the
anti-poaching efforts more effective and
in the process we have developed a tool
called pose
helps them deploy patrolling efforts in
protected areas to catch poachers in the
act in fact a post as I will show you
later has become so successful that now
in the last five months we have
partnered with smart which is a
consortium which includes these three
organizations as long as as well as many
more and smart has a tool which helps
many protected areas record their data
in terms of patrolling effort and
detected illegal activity and build
reports for those protected areas now
Smart is gonna is trying to incorporate
our AI based tools to actually provide
them analytics and a planning component
that will let them have more effective
deployment in the field and therefore we
will allow us to reach more than 600
parts in which smart is currently used
over more than 55 countries so the way
that post works is actually again as a
million mentioned earlier starting from
raw data collected over the years in
these parks that includes the patrolling
as well as the detections of illegal
activity combining it with additional
information such as GS information
across the park on roads rivers the park
boundaries land cover etc and using that
data to build a predictive model of
where we expect there to be the highest
risk of poaching given the the
particular time of the year and the
particular characteristics of a grid
cell in the park okay and together with
this predictive model then we are
actually able to help them with also
with a prescriptive part saying with the
limited resources of Park Rangers that
they have where should they send them at
any particular time and and so this is
combining things like machine learning
together with optimization and game
theory so as I mentioned we have worked
on this over an extended period of time
in particular we have worked closely
with two parts in Uganda and it's a
queen elizabeth and much sun falls
and so using historic data from those
two parks we have developed
progressively more and more accurate
machine learning models for the poaching
risk achieving accuracy of point 86 in
our best current model but we don't stop
there okay that that's our accuracy in
in the lab the most important thing is
to actually see whether these models
really work in the field and so we went
a step further and actually had field
test with both parts over more between
six and nine months where we generated
patrol areas where they had not
previously patrolled some of which areas
were predicted to be high-risk and some
low risk based on our models and later
in Murchison Falls refined that to even
high medium and low risk without telling
the Rangers which is which they Patrol
from six to nine months and at the end
of the day we just looked at the data of
what happened and what we discovered it
in fact the areas where our model was
predicting high risk they were able to
find many more snares per patrol effort
that they spent there so in fact it was
extremely accurate in allocating
resources more effectively than than
just guessing at random so so with this
predictive model in hand now that we
also know it works in the field were
also able to tell them more
strategically of how exactly to send
their rangers to Patrol and incorporate
important on-the-ground constraints such
as where other ranges well should they
start from how much can they work at
most in any given day right and so with
the predictive modeling we do in this
constraint our optimization game
theoretic model is able to generate maps
like that which says exactly where to a
walk and how much effort to spend in
each grid cell depending on the
characteristics of that so and the
corresponding prediction of how likely
they are to detect approaching activity
there so so we are really excited about
in fact going to the deployment stage
working with smart and really getting
the system out
in the world in addition to Rangers one
additional resource that more and more
protected areas are thinking about using
is the use of UAVs in order to augment
the patrolling of humans NGO with which
you're working on this called air
Shepard which is using UAVs driven in
vans during the night and sending those
drones to actually patrol in the real
time for poachers and having people sit
and trying to look at the videos in the
real time to detect poachers called the
Rangers if something is suspicious and
responds FA respond effectively
unfortunately looking at these videos is
extremely difficult and tiring and so
their current set up is is not really
scalable so they came to us in trying to
help them to build a more effective
system so as you can see this black and
white videos during the night with an
infrared camera are extremely difficult
to interpret the there are very low
resolutions the objects we are trying to
detect that extremely small the camera
is moving there's other things like
vegetation and reflection that took
exactly like the little specks that
might be poachers right so it's
extremely hard problem so we built a
system based on deep learning which
somehow the slides are all messed up my
yeah a system based on deep learning to
to predict to interpret these videos
unfortunately labeling the videos is
extremely time-consuming and so we have
a limited amount of training data but we
partnered with Microsoft and their video
engine cold air seemed to actually
created a create a version of it which
simulates the African savanna and
poachers and animals in that African
savanna and so we're able to together
with also a model of a drone flying in
this simulation to the generate
additional simulation data that looks
very much like the real data so together
with the labeled very non cost-effective
labor the real-world data with augmented
simulated data were able to no I guess
it's not going to show the result on
this side to improve the accuracy of our
model but in the RICO and precision much
beyond their current system that they're
using in the field and so they're
actually currently testing it using it
in in actual in their actual events and
we also have a cloud-based
implementation on the of the system so
beyond anti-poaching efforts we also
have several projects related to
conservation planning and informing
decision making makers in how to most
effectively use very limited dollars
allocated to conservation to generate
the most the best ecological impact so
one such project is one such problem we
know how to address is how to inform
preserving landscape connectivity for
species so as the habitat gets more and
more fragmented because of roads
urbanization agriculture etc essentially
species cannot move from one a remnant
of habitat to another which really
jeopardizes their long-term persistence
so what we can do about this that we can
try to selectively try to intervene but
by for example building overpasses over
roads or under passes or protecting
specific areas from urbanization and
essentially providing wildlife corridors
for these animals to to move and and and
preserve their populations however this
is a very difficult problem where you
have multiple opportunities with
different effects and different costs
which interact with each other because
essentially the combination of all these
interventions changed the landscape in
terms of the the best movement pathways
for these animals so we've developed an
algorithm that allows for us to produce
such intervention optimum plants and so
we've tested this in western Montana
where a threatened species called the
Wolverine has several remaining
populations in the green parts but which
are basically disconnected because of a
high urbanization in the remaining
carriers and and the cost of
intervention is also very expensive in
in most most common across most of the
landscape so with our method we are able
to generate a subset of specific
intervention points here in red which
essentially reroute and improve the
movement corridors for this species from
the yellow ones - to the black ones that
are shown here and and help hopefully
the long-term persistence of the species
so this was a brief overview but this
basically just gives you a sample of the
kind of methodologies that we use in the
conservation space again leveraging
machine learning as well as optimization
and game theory to help this NGO thank
you very much
[Applause]